THAT IS HAPPENING AS TOP
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ATTACK HOW
DEMOCRATS WANT TO MOVE FORWARD
AND CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF IS
RUNNING THE INVESTIGATION.
>> THEY ADMIT IT'S A SHAM AND
CHANGING THE PROCESS FOR THE
WORSE.
THEY'RE MAKING ADAM SCHIFF THE
PROSECUTOR, THE JUDGE AND THE
JURY.
THEY'RE DENYING MORE REPUBLICANS
IN THE ROOM AND THOSE IN THE
ROOM ONLY ALLOWING ONE TO ASK A
QUESTION.
>> TO INTERRUPT US CONTINUALLY,
TO COACH THE WITNESS, TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE WITNESS -- WE DON'T
GET ANY WITNESSES AT THIS POINT.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
LAUNCHING A NEW PHASE TO FIGHT
BACK AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
UNIFIED REPUBLICANS ARE
ATTACKING THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST HIM.
AND WE HAVE ALL THIS HAPPENING
TODAY -- KATIE, GO TO YOU FIRST.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE POUNDED ON
THE PROCESS.
AND NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CHANGING.
YOU THINK THE REPUBLICANS WILL
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT ON
PROCESS?
>> I THINK SO BASED ON THE IDEA
THAT THIS DOESN'T FALL INTO THE
REAL IMPEACHMENT CATEGORY ONCE
AGAIN.
IT'S A STEP FORWARD.
THEY'RE TRYING TO OPEN UP SOME
OF THESE HEARINGS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO WATCH AND
SEE.
SO ALL OF US WILL BE HAPPY TO
WATCH THIS OURSELVES RATHER THAN
HEARING FROM ADAM SCHIFF OR EVEN
REPUBLICANS REGURGITATING WHAT
THEY THINK HAPPENED INSIDE THESE
HEARINGS.
BUT IF THEY HAVE THE VOTES TO DO
A REAL INQUIRY AND THOUGHT IT
WAS GOOD, THEY WOULD DO IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE VOTES.
POLLS WHEN ASKED WITH NUANCE
LANGUAGE SHOWS THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS INCLUDING INDEPENDENTS
IN DISTRICTS THAT NANCY PELOSI
WANTS TO KEEP IN 2020 IN THE
HOUSE AREN'T IN FAVOR OF THIS.
SO I THINK THEY'RE MOVING THE
PROCESS, THEY HAVE SET UP THIS
LIST OF RULES.
THE IMPEACHMENT DOCUMENT THAT
THEY RELEASED YESTERDAY LAYS OUT
HOW IT'S GOING TO RUN.
IT DOESN'T MEAN MUCH IN TERMS OF
CHANGING THE GAME HERE FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS PREPARING.
THEY'RE HIRES LAWYERS AND
COMMUNICATION STAFF TO GET AHEAD
OF IT.
IN TERMS OF HOW THIS --
>> Dana: IT'S NOT GOING AWAY.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS ROUNDUP OF
MEDIA TALKING ABOUT THE DAMNING
TESTIMONY.
PLAY THAT.
>> BOMB SHELL IMPEACHMENT
TESTIMONY.
>> ONE OF THE MOST DAMNING
WITNESSES YET.
>> TUESDAY'S EXPLOSIVE
TESTIMONY.
>> BOMB SHELL TESTIMONY TONIGHT.
>> DAMNING TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL
HILL.
>> SOME EXPLOSIVE NEWS.
>> HOW DAMNING THE TESTIMONY MAY
BE.
>> AFTER THAT EXPLOSIVE
TESTIMONY.
>> IT'S VERY DAMNING TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> BOMB SHELL TESTIMONY BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> CREATING THIS DAMNING
PORTRAIT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: JESSE, I SAID
REPUBLICANS HAVE POUNDED ON
PROCESS FOR A MONTH.
THE DEMOCRATS, LIKE EVERY DAY,
THEY HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE OUT
THERE WITH DAMNING TESTIMONY.
>> Jessie: WELL, IF IT'S THIS
BIG BOMB SHELL WE SHOULD SEE THE
EXPLOSION.
WE CAN'T SEE A GLIMMER OF
EXPLOSION BECAUSE IT'S ALL DONE
IN THE DARK.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ROUND TO
POUND THIS DEAL ON PROCESS
BECAUSE IT'S CORRUPT, CROOKED
AND SHADY.
IT'S BEING RUN BY ADAM SCHIFF,
THE CHIEF ARCHITECT OF THE
RUSSIAN HOAX WHO HAS ALREADY
BEEN CAUGHT WITNESS TAMPERING
AND NOW WITNESS COACHING AND
TRYING TO FIND NAKED PICTURES OF
TRUMP.
SO HE'S BEEN SLAPPED WITH AN
ETHICS COMPLAINTS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE RIPPING IT
AWAY FROM SCHIFF AND GIVING IT
TO JERRY NADLER TO HANDLE.
BUT HE HAS A GOOD ARGUMENT.
I'LL RAISE THE TREATY A LOT OF
TIMES.
ASK UKRAINE ABOUT CORRUPTION AND
JOE BIDEN IS NOT ABOVE THE LOVE.
KATIE CITED GREAT POLLS.
JUAN LOVES TO TALK ABOUT POLLS.
THIS IS A CNN REPORT.
IMPEACHMENT IS NOT POPULAR IN
WISCONSIN AND THESE FIVE OTHER
KEY SWING STATES.
I DON'T NEED TO READ IT.
IT'S ALL HERE.
I HAVE ANOTHER POLL HERE THAT
SAYS --
>> Dana: YOU'RE --
>> Jessie: 59% DON'T WANT THE
PRESIDENT IMPEACH.
ONLY 36% DO.
THAT'S SUFFOLK UNIVERSITY, "USA
TODAY" AND 38% SAY THE PHONE
CALL WAS IMPEACHABLE.
51% SAY IT'S NOT AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> Dana: JUAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT POLL CASE?
>> IT'S BOGUS.
>> Jessie: OH, JUAN.
DON'T RUN DOWN THE POLLSTERS.
>> Juan: THE NATIONAL POLLS ARE
CONSISTENT FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THE NATIONAL STORY IS CLEAR.
I'M GOING TO SAY THIS.
TRUMP AND HIS FOLKS HAVE BEEN
ARGUING PROCESS, PROCESS FOR
WEEKS.
EVEN TO THE POINT OF ATTACKING
LIEUTENANT COLONEL VINDMAN AND
DEFAMING HIM THAT IS SO
UNPATRIOTIC.
THE REASON THEY ARGUED PROCESS,
THE FACTS ARE NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
NOW THE PROCESS IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
PELOSI, THE SPEAKER HAS FOLLOWED
THE CONSTITUTION TO THE LETTER
AND NOW THEY'RE MOVING TO AN
OPEN PHASE, WHICH IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS
HAVE ASKED FOR AND SAY IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
BUT THE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING
TO WORK YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND SAY OH, DON'T BUY
IT.
DON'T BUY IT.
AGAIN, THESE POLLS ARE VERY
CLEAR.
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT OH
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT O
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT --
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT -- E
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT -- EVE
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT -- EVEN
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT -- EVEN T
PEOPLE SAY THEY WANT -- EVEN THE
TRANSCRIPT THAT TRUMP SAID OH,
IT'S PERFECT, PERFECT PHONE
CALL.
NOW WE KNOW FROM LIEUTENANT
COLONEL VINDMAN IT WASN'T --
>> Dana: WE KNEW THAT.
I HAVE TO PLAY THIS FOR YOU.
>> Juan: PLEASE DO.
>> Dana: IT'S ABOUT FACTS.
>> THEY STILL DON'T HAVE WHAT
YOU WOULD CALL THE GOODS ON THIS
PRESIDENT IN TERMS OF BREAKING
THE LAW AND BEING AN IMPEACHABLE
TARGET FOR THEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO START THE
PROCESS BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CLARITY THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO RICHARD NIXON HAD.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THAT?
>> Greg: I THINK A LOT OF THAT.
LOOK, WHAT THE DEMS ARE DOING IS
CREATING A TRAIN OF OPINIONS
THAT ARE ALL ABOUT THE ONE
THING, THE TRANSCRIPT.
SO THEY FIND ANOTHER GUY TO SAY
YEAH, I WAS CONCERNED, TOO.
SO IT'S A TRAIN OF CONCERN.
BUT CONCERN IS NOT THE SAME AS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS THE STORY OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT MANY
THINGS THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
TRUMP'S INSTABILITY, TRUMP'S
INSANE.
THE STOCK MARKET IS GOING TO
CRASH.
EVERY TIME THEY WORRY ABOUT IT,
BE CONFIDENT IT WON'T HAPPEN.
I WONDER IF THERE'S A LINK
BETWEEN THE IMPEACHMENT
HYSTERIA -- COULD IT BE IT'S
DRAINING THE PART OF THE
INTELLECTUAL ENERGY?
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN WALK AND
CHEW GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THE NEXT
ELECTION BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
CONCENTRATE.
THEY'RE LIKE A CO-WORKER, RIGHT?
THAT DOES EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
GET OUT OF THE JOB THAT THEY'RE
DOING, THAT THEY END UP ACTUALLY
DOING MORE WORK TO GET OUT OF
THE WORK --
>> Dana: CAUSING MORE WORK.
>> Greg: CAUSING MORE WORK FOR
THEMSELVES SO RIGHT NOW
AMERICA -- WE PREDICTED THIS.
AMERICANS ARE KIND OF FIGURING
THIS OUT.
THEY KNOW THIS IS A SNOW JOB.
THEY KNOW IT'S OUT OF PROPORTION
TO WHAT HAPPENED.
AND I KNOW -- PEOPLE MAKE A BIG
DEAL ABOUT DEFAMING VINDMAN.
THE SAME THING WERE SAYING ABOUT
TULSI A FULL WEEK AGO.
YOU CALLED HER A RUSSIAN ASSET.
>> Juan: I THINK HILLARY CLINTON
CALLED HER A RUSSIAN ASSET AND I
WROTE THAT SHE IS A RUSSIAN
ASSET.
>> Dana: YOU'RE ANTI-PATRIOTIC.
>> Greg: YOU'RE SO NOT
PATRIOTIC, JUAN.
>> Juan: IT'S SO WILDLY WRONG,
IT'S TRUMP TRYING TO RALLY
REPUBLICANS AND SAY HEY, THE
CULT HAS TO STAND BEHIND ME.
DO EVERYTHING.
>> Greg: CALLING SUPPORTERS A
CULT REFLECTS BADLY ON YOU,
JUAN.
THAT DOESN'T PERSUADE ANYBODY.
I LAUGH AT IT.
>> Juan: IT'S ALL ABOUT TRUMP
AND -- DON'T EVEN BACK THE
REPUBLICANS, BACK TRUMP.
>> Greg: CALL PEOPLE A CULT.
>> Juan: THIS IS NOT JUST
BACKING TRUMP.
I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
IN A DIFFERENT PLACE.
>> Jessie: YOU CAN'T CRACK THE
BASE, JUAN.
YOU CAN'T.
>> Greg: THEY'RE ON CRACK.
>> Dana: KATIE, TWO THINGS.
WE HAVE HEARD THE WHITE HOUSE
EVENT WILL HAPPEN IN JUST A
MINUTE OR SO.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP TALKING
HERE.
ONE THING THIS DOES, INCUMBENCY,
THERE'S A LOT OF BENEFITS TO IT.
YOU CAN SET UP A CONTRAST.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THE EAST
ROOM.
HE'S DOING A MEDAL OF HONOR
CEREMONY.
HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE PENTAGON
IS SET TO RELEASE -- JUST GOT
THIS BREAKING NEWS -- VIDEO OF
THE RAID.
YOU CAN SHOW AND YOU CAN TELL
PEOPLE ALL THE THINGS YOU'RE
DOING WHEN THE CONTRAST IS ON
THE HILL THAT YOU HAVE
IMPEACHMENT EVERY DAY, THIS IS A
VIDEO, KATIE.
YOU CAN SEE THE PENTAGON JUST
RELEASED THIS.
THIS HAPPENED LATE SATURDAY
NIGHT.
THIS IS THE COMPOUND WHERE
BAGHDADI WAS BEING HOLED UP.
YOU CAN SEE THE SPECIAL FORCES.
VERY UNUSUAL FOR THE PENTAGON TO
RELEASE THIS TYPE OF VIDEO.
THEY MUST HAVE BELIEVED THAT
THEY HAD ALL THE INTELLIGENCE
THAT THEY NEEDED CLEARED OUT OF
THE WAY TO RELEASE IT AND SHOW
PEOPLE WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YEAH, AL-BAGHDADI RAN INTO A
HOLE AND DECIDED TO BE A COWARD
AND NOT FIGHT BACK.
I'M GLAD HE'S GONE.
THE PRESIDENT DESERVES CREDIT
FOR IT.
YOU'RE 100% RIGHT THAT THIS SETS
UP A CONTRAST.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS FOCUSED ON
DEFENDING THE COUNTRY FROM ISIS,
THE NATIONAL SECURITY AND PUSH
FORWARD THINGS ON CAPITOL HILL.
I WAS ON CAPITOL HILL YESTERDAY.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS THAT LIKE IOWA THAT
ARE GETTING PUSHED ON ISSUES --
>> Dana: WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK AND BE BACK WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN THE EAST ROOM.
WE'LL BE BACK.
♪♪
No. In the basement.
Why can't we just get in the
running car?
Are you crazy? Let's hide behind
the chainsaws.